A FEDERAL JUDGE DROPPING A LABOR
DAY BOMBSHELL, GRANTING A
SPECIAL REQUEST FOR AN
INDEPENDENT MASTER FOR A REVIEW
OF ALL THE DOCUMENTS SEIZED FROM
FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP'S
MAR-A-LAGO ESTATE.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT SAID IT
WOULD IMPEDE IN THE
INVESTIGATION, BUT THE JUDGE
DISAGREED.
OUR KARA SCANNELL IS HERE IN NEW
YORK.
ALSO WITH US CONSTITUTIONAL LAW
ATTORNEY PAIGE.
LET ME START WITH YOU.
THIS IS NO SLOW LABOR DAY.
TALK ABOUT THE IMMEDIATE IMPACT
OF THIS FILING.
>> SURPRISE FOR SURE ON LABOR
DAY.
RIGHT NOW WITH THIS RULING THE
JUDGE IS SAYING THAT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS ENJOYING IT.
THEY'RE BLOCKED NOW FROM
REVIEWING AND USING ANY OF THE
MATERIALS THAT WERE SEIZED AT
MAR-A-LAGO.
REMEMBER, THAT'S MORE THAN
11,000 DOCUMENTS AS WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT ON FRIDAY, SO THE
JUDGE IS SAYING THEY CANNOT LOOK
AT THIS ANYMORE.
IT'S GOING TO GO TO THE SPECIAL
MASTER, THAT SHE'S SAYING SHE'S
GRANTED THE REQUEST FROM DONALD
TRUMP TO APPOINT, BUT SHE'S
GIVING UNTIL FRIDAY FOR A LIST
OF NAMES OF PEOPLE WHO CAN SERVE
IN THAT ROLE WHO HAVE SECURITY
CLEARANCE BECAUSE HUNDREDS OF
THE DOCUMENTS ARE CLASSIFIED AS
WE KNOW.
RIGHT NOW'S A PAUSE UNTIL THE
SPECIAL MASTER FINISHES THE
REVIEW.
WE HAD A SENSE OF IT WITH THE
NUMBER OF VUMTS.
>> THIS POLITICALLY IS A WIN FOR
THE PRESIDENT, NO?
>> ABSOLUTELY THIS IS A
POLITICAL WIN.
DONALD TRUMP IS GETTING ALMOST
EVERYTHING THAT HE HAS ASKED FOR
IN THIS.
AND IN HER COURT FILING DATA,
THE JUDGE POINTS OUT THE
EXTRAORDINARY NATURE OF THIS.
HERE'S WHAT SHE WROTE.
AS A FUNCTION OF PLAINTIFF'S
FORMER POSITION AS PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES, THE STIGMA
ASSOCIATED WITH THE SUBJECT
SEIZURE IS IN A LEAGUE OF ITS
OWN, A FUTURE INDICTMENT BASED
ON ANY DEGREE WOULD RESULT IN
REPUTATIONAL HARM OF A DECIDEDLY
DIFFERENT ORDER OF MAGNITUDE.
THIS IS THE FORMER PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES WHO'S NOT
RULED OUT ANOTHER RUN.
THE JUDGE IS TAKING ANOTHER STEP
TO MAKE SURE IT IS REVIEWED BY
AN OUTSIDE PARTY.
>> LEGALLY DOES THIS HELP TRUMP.
>> NOT A LOT, ANA.
IT MAY BE A POLITICAL WIN FOR
TRUMP, BUT IT'S NOT MUCH OF A
LEGAL WIN.
THE MOTION THEY FILED FOR THE
REQUEST OF A SPECIAL MASTER, IT
INCLUDED A LOT OF NONSENSE ABOUT
THE ELECTION AND FAIRNESS, WHO
SHOULD HAVE WON.
IT'S ALL POLITICAL.
TO HAVE A REQUEST OF A SPECIAL
MASTER TO REVIEW THE DOCUMENTS,
IT'S NOT THAT CRAZY.
IT DOES HAPPEN IN FEDERAL COURT.
IT MAY SLOW DOWN THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT'S INVESTIGATION
SOMEWHAT, BUT NOT A LOT.
DOJ HAS ALREADY INFORMED THIS
COURT THAT, HEY, WE'VE LOOKED AT
THESE DOCUMENTS.
WE KNOW WHAT THEY ARE.
WE SENT SOME OF THEM FOR
ANALYSIS OF THE IMPACT OF
NATIONAL SECURITY AND THE
DOCUMENTS HAVE BEEN AT
MAR-A-LAGO.
THAT DEPARTMENT'S INVESTIGATION
MAY CONTINUE ON.
WHILE IT MAY BE A SETBACK, I
DON'T THINK IT'S A SIGNIFICANT
ONE.
>> THE JUDGE DID APPEAR TO PUSH
BACK ON ONE ARGUMENT SAYING,
QUOTE, THERE'S NOT BEEN A
COMPELLING SHOWING OF CALLOUS
DISREGARD FOR PLAINTIFF'S
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS.
PAGE, IS IT SIGNIFICANT THAT
THAT'S NOW ON THE RECORD WITH
THIS JUDGE?
>> I THINK SO.
THAT POINTS TO THE FACT THIS IS
NOT AS SIGNIFICANT AS SOME
PEOPLE ARE SAYING.
THE JUDGE IS NOT SAYING THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WAS WRONG.
NOT SAYING THEY TOOK STUFF THEY
SHOULD NOT HAVE TOOK, AND
CERTAINLY NOT SAYING THIS
INVESTIGATION IS POLITICAL OR
NOT PROPERLY FOUNDED IN THE LAW.
WHAT THE JUDGE IS SAYING, LOOK,
I UNDERSTAND YOU SAY YOU'VE HAD
YOUR OWN TEAM LOOK AT.
THIS BUT LET'S HAVE SOMEONE
INDEPENDENT, SOMEONE FROM THE
OUTSIDE LOOK OVER THEIR
SHOULDER.
PERHAPS THAT TAKES SOME OF THE
POLITICS OUT, BUT IT'S NOT A
REJECTION OF THE GOVERNMENT'S
INVESTIGATION, NOT AT ALL.
>> I KNOW, KARA, YOU'VE BEEN
PORING OVER THE 24-PAGE RULING
THAT JUST CAME DOWN.
THERE ARE ALSO MORE DETAILS IN
THIS ABOUT WHAT WAS SEIZED.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
ONE OF THE THINGS THE JUDGE IS
APPOINTING THE SPECIAL MASTER
FOR IS NOT ONLY FOR THE ISSUES
OF ATTORNEY/CLIENT PRIVILEGE BUT
ALSO PERSONAL DOCUMENTS.
WHAT SHE INFORMS US IN THIS
OPINION IS AMONG THE DOCUMENTS
THAT WERE SEIZED WERE SOME OF
TRUMP'S MEDICAL RECORDS, SOME
RELATED TO HIS TAXES, AND SOME
RELATED TO HIS ACCOUNTING, WHICH
IS OF INTEREST BECAUSE THERE ARE
ALL THESE OTHER INVESTIGATIONS
INVOLVING SOME OF THE SAME
ISSUES, THE JUDGE SAYING SHE'LL
GO THROUGH AND FIGURE IT OUT.
THE REASON SHE'S DOING THIS IS
FOR THE PERCEPTION OF FAIRNESS.
YOU KNOW, SHE SAID THERE WERE
SOME CONCERNS THAT THE FILTER
TEAM HAD ALREADY PROVIDED ONE OR
TWO DOCUMENTS TO THE
INVESTIGATIVE TEAM THAT THEY
SHOULDN'T HAVE, AND SHE WANTS TO
PUT THIS IN PLACE AS ANOTHER
BLOCKER.
>> EVEN THOUGH, PAGE, THE
ATTORNEYS AND TRUMP WERE ON
OPPOSITE SIDES OF THE ISSUE, THE
JUDGE IS SAYING NOW THEY NEED TO
AGREE ON A POSSIBLE LIST OF
SPECIAL MASTER CANDIDATES AND A
PROPOSAL FOR COMMUNICATION
ABILITIES, SCHEDULE FOR REVIEW,
COMPENSATION.
HOW NUNL UNUSUAL IS THAT?
>> IT'S NOT UNUSUAL AT ALL, BUT
IT MAY BE DIFFICULT DO HERE.
IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE EITHER SIDE
HAS AGREED ON ANYTHING.
THE JUDGE NOTED HER ORDER THE
TRUMP TEAM CAME TO DOJ BEFORE
THIS MOTION WAS FILED, ASKED
THAT THERE BE A SPECIAL MASTER.
THE JUSTICE SAID, NO, WE'RE NOT
GOING TO DO THAT.
CAN WE GET TOGETHER AND AGREE?
THAT WOULD BE THE NORMAL COURSE.
IN THE CASE IT DID NOT INVOLVE
THE FORMER PRESIDENT, THE JUDGE
WOULD SAY BOTH SIDES NEED TO
PRESENT A SPECIAL MASTER FOR THE
COURT'S APPROVAL AND HOW THE
PROCESS WOULD WORK.
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY CAN AGREE
ON IT, BUT IF THEY CAN'T, THE
JUDGE CAN DO IT HERSELF.
>> KARA ALSO POINTED OUT GIVEN
THERE ARE SO MANY CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS INCLUDING TOP SECRETS,
DOES THAT NARROW DOWN WHO COULD
BE ASSIGNED AS SPECIAL MASTER?
>> OH, ABSOLUTELY.
WHOEVER REVIEWS THESE DOCUMENTS
HAS TO HAVE THE PROPER
CLASSIFICATION AND CLEARANCE TO
LOOK AT THE STUFF BECAUSE YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO LOOK AT ALL THE
DOCUMENTS AGAIN TO DETERMINE IF
THE INTERNAL REVIEW TEAM MAY
HAVE MISSED ANY PRIVILEGED
DOCUMENTS OR PERSONAL DOCUMENTS.
YES, IT'S GOING TO BE A VERY
SHORT LIST OF POTENTIAL SPECIAL
MASTERS.
>> SARA, TELL US MORE HOW THIS
COULD IMPACT THE TIMELINE OF THE
INVESTIGATION.
>> OBVIOUSLY FOR THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IT'S DIFFICULT
BECAUSE IT HOLDS THEIR ABILITY
TO ACCESS AND REVIEW THE
DOCUMENTS.
THEY COULD STILL BE TALKING TO
WITNESSES, STILL HAVE SOME GRAND
JURY GOIGS ON.
YOU MAY WANT TO SHOW THE
DOCUMENTS, MAY WANT TO REFER
BACK TO THE DOCUMENTS.
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS GOING TO BE ABLE
TO DO IN THIS INTERIM PERIOD.
AGAIN, WE DON'T KNOW HOW LONG
THIS IS GOING TO TAKE.
AS KARA POINTED OUT, WE HAVE A
GOOD SENSE WE'RE TALKING UPWARDS
OF 11,000 DOCUMENTS.
WE JUST DON'T KNOW HOW LONG THAT
TIME FRAME WILL TAKE AND HOW
MUCH THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WILL
BE RELYING ON THE DOCUMENTS AS
THEY'RE PRESENTING BEFORE A
GRAND JURY.
>> RIGHT.
SHE'S NOT SAYING PAUSE YOUR
INVESTIGATION.
SHE'S JUST SAYING PAUSE YOUR
PROCESSING AND REVIEW OF THESE
SPECIFIC MATERIALS THAT ARE PART
OF YOUR INVESTIGATION.
KARA, COULD THE DOJ APPEAL THIS?
>> YEAH.
IT'S REAL INTERESTING.
LAST WEEK AT THE COURT HEARING
THE JUDGE ASKED HER IN THAT
ORDER A CERTAIN WAY TO ALLOW THE
MECHANISM TO APPEAL.
WE DIDN'T KNOW AT THE TIME WHAT
THIS WAS GOING TO LOOK LIKE, HOW
SHE WOULD RULE, BUT CERTAINLY
IT'S SOMETHING THE DOJ SEEMS TO
BE THINKING ABOUT.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY COMMENT, IF
TLA'LL APPEAL OR NOT APPEAL.
BUT THEY WERE LOOKING FOR A
MECHANISM IN WHICH THEY COULD DO
THAT.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
KARA, THANK YOU.
ALSO TO SARA AND PAGE PATE,
APPRECIATE YOU JOINING US.